another group of sexy ladies take over
TV tonight on The Bachelor and only our
lauren zima tag along for their group
date where everyone got all golden looks
amazing you know we walked off the bus
today all we saw him was shirtless and
like glowing like honestly he was so hot
eight women one shirtless bachelor this
was the first time the women saw you
with your shirt off oh my god how did
that feel good I don't know can we just
get one glimpse of the ABS they're a
little rough right now I'll take it
the theme of this group date strong
women on the agenda a marriage pep talk
from Terry Crews and his wife a workout
and a competition my reason for coming
on the show was to show him what a
strong woman look like and my wife she
epitomizes what a strong woman is there
are quite a few really strong
connections that I'm very very very
excited about we couldn't help but
notice Colton was quick to help Cassie
with her pull-ups I definitely have a
big crush my uncle's in right now at
this point could you see yourself
walking down the aisle with him over
here and just by being surrounded by at
least five cameras Sydney snuck away
with Colton for some stretching I'm a
dancer in like a fitness instructor so I
hop this feels like a good date for me
but after 29 years of marriage Terry
made some observations of his own I saw
the ones that didn't connect
they were pretty obvious I was like oh
okay
[Music]